[Music]
Hey
good afternoon everyone first off thanks
for coming today I'm really excited to
be here my name is Michael you I'm a
software developer on Google Cloud
Storage and with me today is James
Malone
he's a product manager on Google cloud
data proc so over the last couple years
I've had the opportunity to work with a
bunch of our users and see some of the
issues that they run into so today what
we were hoping to do was go over some of
the common issues that we see and some
of the common misconceptions as well as
some of the common solutions and we're
only gonna touch a handful of these
there's enough time to really cover a
lot of them but what we're also hoping
to do is give you a little bit of
insight in terms of how the service is
working and why we made certain design
decisions that can can lead to certain
problems so hopefully this will be
really interesting and useful and fun
here's the agenda for today the talks
broken down into four main sections the
first two sections to cover our primary
use cases which are data processing and
content serving so for data processing
workloads and content we're going to
first talk about storage classes and the
reason why is that there's some
misconceptions around them particularly
we've we've commonly seen that some
folks believe that multi-regional is a
strictly superior storage class at
regional and that's not true there's
actually trade-offs between the two and
so we'll go into some of the latency
differences and some of the consistency
differences we're also going to talk
about roughly you know what performance
you can expect at GCS and we're going to
talk about how to change your access
patterns to take advantage of our
relative strengths and hopefully work
around some of our relative weaknesses
the third section is going to be on
right scaling this is a problem that we
see fairly often folks will end up
hitting a bottleneck and they're not
able to scale the number of writes for a
second they can get so we're going to
take a look at some of the design
decisions that we made that resulted in
this hot spotting and we'll sort of
explain our rationale for making those
decisions and then we'll of course talk
about ways to get around that and then
finally we're gonna wrap up talking
about retries you know retries is
probably something everyone's familiar
with but there's different strategies
you want to use when dealing with errors
versus dealing with slow requests and
tail latency so we're going to talk
about a technique called hedge requests
which is a good way to deal with
you can see okay so let's get to the
first section which is data processing
workloads and hopefully guys are all
familiar with storage classes for GCS
but let me do a quick overview for those
who aren't so we have four main classes
multi regional regional near line and
cold line for the multi-regional storage
class what we guarantee is that you're
gonna have at least two replicas and
they're gonna be geo diverse so the
replicas are going to be located at
least 100 miles apart so in this
particular example we have four objects
there's a replica for each of them in
this left region and then the second
replicas for the other four objects are
split between the middle in the right
region the second storage class is
regional and here you select a very
specific region to store your data and
we guarantee that all of your data lies
within that region the last two source
classes are near lining cold line
they're designed for colder data they're
a little bit cheaper to store your data
they cost a little bit more to access
your data and in this example up here
the the main thing I wanted to call out
is that for near line and cold line you
can choose either a regional location or
a multi regional location but they don't
really provide geo diversity within a
single object so in this particular case
object one is in the left region object
two is in the middle region neither of
those objects are actually split between
multiple regions okay so here's a table
that shows the relative strengths and
weaknesses of our various stores classes
and for data processing workloads I
wanted to call out two attributes so the
first is local agency right your data
processing workloads you want to locate
your computer next to your storage and
regional has much tighter local agency
balance this is actually maybe not as
obvious as it might seem the reason why
is for multi regional we have multiple
replicas and as long as a replica is
near your computer you might think the
latency is going to be okay right but
there are reality is is that for a multi
regional storage class you define an
overall multi region that will you store
your data in such as a US or Asia or you
and you don't have really fine grained
control over exactly which regions
within the multi region that are used
and so even though we do make an attempt
to keep your data in the region that you
initially wrote it in
over time it can migrate out and that
can result in higher tail latency the
second reason that local agency isn't is
great is a little bit more subtle and
that has to do with the right latency so
for the multi-regional storage class we
of course replicate your data to two
different locations and we need to
maintain some type of metadata that says
where your data is actually located and
this metadata has to be replicated to
multiple regions as well right if we
didn't then we're not really providing a
true fault tolerance across regions so
that's one aspect the other aspect is
that GCS provides strong read after
write consistency so that means if I
write an object we guarantee that every
read afterwards is gonna see this latest
version so when you when you look at
those two pieces combined okay what's
that what that implies is that - you're
gonna have two synchronicity will
replicate your metadata app and so every
write is gonna result in at least one
remote round-trip out of the region and
so no matter how much we optimize you're
gonna be bound by that net that Network
latency so local agency is one big
reason why you want to use regional for
data processing the other reason is
actually something pretty cool that we
haven't announced I think until now and
that is for the regional storage class
as well as any near liner cold line
bucket that uses a regional location
we're now guaranteeing strong list after
right consistency so this means that if
you write an object and then you
immediately list your objects the newly
written object is gonna show up we
guarantee that and if you delete an
object and then list all your objects
that object was guaranteed to not show
up so now all of a sudden your workloads
can really rely on this strong
consistency which can be really useful
and we don't yet have this for a multi
regional so it's a pretty strong reason
to go ahead and use regional next we
want to talk a little bit about some of
the performance characteristics of GCS
these are really really rough rules of
thumb I essentially tried to make the
first number be powers or two but
they're you know they're relatively
accurate and the thing to notice here is
that GCS is relatively strong in terms
single-stream throughput you know we
think we get usually roughly around 800
megabits per second for reads for two
megabits per second for writes on the
flip side we're relatively weak in terms
of the fixed latency cost per request
and so a rough rule of thumb is 100
milliseconds for reading 200
milliseconds for writes so there's a
couple of implications here so first is
obviously favor larger requests right
take advantage of that throughput second
of all if you do have some if you do
have small requests parallel eyes them
right so that way you're really
overlapping that fixed cost fixed
latency cost and then finally this is a
little is subtle but in general for data
processing workloads you want to avoid
resumable uploads especially for small
requests and the definition of small is
somewhat surprising sometimes right does
that mean five megabytes or ten
megabytes maybe 100 megabytes well if
you look at our four new mega is per
second right that's equivalent to 50
megabytes per second right if you have a
one gigabyte size object that means that
a one gigabyte size object can be
written in about 20 seconds so if you're
willing to give up up to 20 seconds of
work in the rare case that you encounter
an error then you actually don't really
need to be using resumable and the
reason why we don't recommend resume for
these small requests is that a resumable
upload requires at least two round trips
to the server right the first round trip
establishes a unique session that you
then use in your second round trip to
upload your data and again because we
had this fixed latency cost that's going
to add up over time I actually wanted to
mention kind of an interesting story we
were we actually ran into this ourselves
once where we were doing some
benchmarking using test DFS i/o what
this does is essentially spins up a
bunch of workers and it does a bunch of
Rights and does a bunch of read so it's
a very simple i/o test and when we ran
this benchmark it was taking a little
bit longer than we expected so we dug in
and the reading in the writing portion
was actually quite quick you know it was
sort of scaling as we expected however
the job was taking a long time to start
up so when we dug into that even further
what we noticed is that the controller
was writing these small control files
to coordinate all the workers right and
was running these small files serially
one by one
it was also using resumable uploads so
that meant H file actually required two
round trips to the server so if you kind
of do the rough napkin math we're
talking about 400 milliseconds per
control file maybe two and a half
control files per second you're talking
about spinning up a thousand workers
you're already talking about 400 seconds
or about six or seven minutes just to
start off the job so you know in
hindsight it was pretty obvious but it's
kind of a lesson where if you're taking
a workload from an existing system and
you're moving it to GCS the performance
characteristics are can be different and
so you know you want to take that into
account and make sure your parallelizing
okay up next James is gonna do a quick
demo on cloud data proc that should
hopefully show some of these principles
in play so excellent thank you all for
being here it's nice to see all of you
so I'm a product manager and I focus on
Google Cloud Data proc data proc is our
managed spark and Hadoop offering and
the demo I'm going to show you is really
important because one of the principal
things that we try to do with data proc
many of our products has really separate
storage and compute and with spark and
Hadoop usually the storage is
intrinsically tied to your cluster so
often with spark and Hadoop you have the
Hadoop distributed file system or HDFS
that often lives with your cluster and a
lot of times you have to scale your
cluster to store data and Hadoop is
tried to solve many of the hard things
that GCS solves behind the scenes for
you like replication like performance
durability by being able to use Google
Cloud Storage you can have your data
live in Google Cloud and use it with
data proc or any other multiple other
products and you spark and Hadoop on
that data as you wish so the demo I'm
going to show you today is twofold one
I'm going to show you a spark streaming
example that takes advantage of the list
consistency that's built into regional
buckets what's really cool about that is
as soon as we're writing files to this
cloud storage bucket spark streaming is
picking them up and processing them
that's often a very difficult thing to
do with cloud environments and block
stores and the second is as Mike said
we're some of the numbers we showed you
that's great I love showing numbers I'm
a big fan of actually showing you the
numbers in real time so I want to
substantiate
some of the performance that we're
seeing and talk about how we're really
trying to enhance performance with cloud
data proc and cloud storage so the first
thing I am going to do here and I'll
come back to this I'm going to submit a
job against to spark cluster z' these
jobs are going to test a change that we
recently made that I'll talk about that
demonstrate some of the performance
enhancements and underlying performance
characteristics of cloud storage
these are Hadoop jobs and behind the
scenes I'm actually just running test
DFS IO to sort of link the stories
together here and we're going to read 20
files that are thousand megabytes apiece
so I'm going to go ahead and just kick
off these two jobs with cloud data proc
we have a control plane to submit work
to spark in Hadoop clusters you don't
have to go in and use the really
complicated Hadoop tools and of course
that just is problematic the next thing
I'm going to do is run through a demo to
show you spark streaming and some of the
advantages of using consistency that's
built into regional buckets so I have
two clusters here I'm going to go ahead
and create these clusters and these
clusters are going to go and actually
read data from my cloud storage bucket
and they're in the process of of
creating and I'll actually show you we
generally can create spark and Hadoop
clusters in like 60 to 90 seconds which
is why I'm totally comfortable standing
up here and creating a spark and Hadoop
clusters in the demo here and you can
see this on the very bottom and I
apologize it's a one-line shell script
but I want to show you exactly what
we're doing we're going to copy data
from one bucket to another and if it's
somewhat not not obvious by the script
here I've downloaded a bunch of books
from the Gutenberg collection so these
are text files that range from like 10
kilobytes to 4 megabytes the goal here
is to show you this is typical kind of
log data like it's going to be variable
size it's not going to be huge and it
takes advantage of some of the things
that we would recommend if you're using
spark and Hadoop with with Google Cloud
Storage ultimately I'm going to copy
these files kind of
one at a time just to show you that
streaming against these files works I'm
sleeping for eight seconds with a
cluster just so you can actually see the
output unfortunately Google Cloud
storage and cloud data proc are so fast
that if I did it all at once you just
see a big blur of text and it looks cool
and it looks like your job is working in
warp speed but it's really hard to see
so we're gonna do is we'll kick off this
spark streaming job and the spark
streaming job and if you don't believe
me the file name is actually even the
same this is just a canonical like spark
streaming example it's actually from the
spark documentation and it's just
reading data from HDFS or so spark
thinks so we have a cloud storage
connector for spark and Hadoop that's
lives on Cloud Data proc and it can read
and write from cloud storage and assumes
it's HDFS and the reason is is that we
implement the Hadoop file system API so
we can interact with cloud storage as if
it were HDFS that's attached to the
cluster itself so we're gonna run this
word count and it's just running it
against bucket which is a regional
bucket that has strong consistency these
two clusters that I created next demo
one index demo two are in two different
regions and the reason that I did that
was to show you that we can actually
have two clusters reading from the same
bucket at the same time and this is
really powerful because we're actually
operating with two different SPARC and
Hadoop clusters against one cloud
storage bucket at the very same time in
two completely different regions the
first cluster is inside of the US region
the second is inside of the EU region
and we're reading a data bucket that is
inside of the US region so it's actually
really neat to see that this just kind
of magically works so you can see here
I've already started streaming files and
actually this will be a bit more
meaningful here if we go and go back to
our let's look at the jobs here
I'll just use this time so as we're
streaming data to this bucket you can
see that we're basically performing word
counts in real time and I'm actually
getting the real-time output of these
files as they're being written if we
actually make this cloud shell bigger
and I apologize this is just the
unfortunate side-effect of presenting on
a very large screen um so we're actually
just copying these files over one at a
time and putting them in that bucket as
soon as they appear in that bucket
they're being instantly picked up and
processed by cloud data proc so when you
saw the console you saw that we had just
written a file here's the word count of
that file and every second spark is
looking for new files and it's doing a
word count on them instantly there's not
magic here it's not complicated
literally all we're doing is putting
what is a substitute for log data in a
bucket and our spark and Hadoop clusters
are immediately able to process that
data if we look at the first job that I
kicked off the other thing I want to
share with you is we've made
improvements to our cloud storage
connector for spark and Hadoop so we
read 20 files that were a thousand
megabytes
our average i/o throughput was 217
megabytes per second if we translate
that to megabits per second we're
looking at well over 1,600 megabits per
second so 800 may be a great rule but
your mileage may vary of course
depending on your workloads but in
general this is to show you that when we
say it's performant we're not just
saying as performant it really is
performant all of these examples will
also be on our github repository just in
case you want to run through them and
test them so as I talked about there's a
few best practices that we'd recommend
if consistency matters use regional
buckets we recommend generally that you
keep your clusters and buckets close
together and the reason for that is you
know if you're doing things like stream
processing milliseconds can matter and
the closer that all of your operations
are occurring to each other the better
if you have a lot of operations paralyze
them because as I showed you can read
from one bucket at the same time you can
have multiple clusters paralyzed or you
can have jobs paralyzed we update
cloud data proc in our cloud storage
connector for spark and Hadoop
frequently the SSL improvements that you
saw us we're actually reading at 1600
megabyte megabits per second is rolling
out in the next week or two if you are
using spark in Hadoop 8 cores per VM
will give you the maximum performance
just based on our hour-long testing and
don't use wildcards in silly ways so
whenever you do a wild-card you're going
to get a list of the entire bucket
don't try and list a large bucket if you
only need to operate on a subset of the
files because you're gonna get back way
more data than you actually need to
operate and with that I will turn it
back over thanks James ok let's move on
to content serving so this is any use
case where you have content stored in
GCS you want to distribute it to users
or potentially all over the globe right
I showed the slide previously the one
thing I wanted to call out is
multi-regional can be a good source
class to use in this case the primary
reason is that you get better remote
latency due to having multiple replicas
and of course you get better
availability due to having geo diversity
alright and here things like list
consistency they don't typically matter
as much right
so one of the things that I think not
everyone knows about GCS is that we have
this pretty nice global network we do
edge caching video core caching and so
what does that actually mean
so I without any of this typically what
would happen when a user fetches a
object is the request would traverse
across the public internet and it would
eventually hit the region that the
objects located in in what did ingress
at the Google network at that region we
would serve the object and the response
would flow back over the public Internet
so what GCS actually does is we have
Google as points of presence all over
the globe and we try to get the users
requests on to our nearest point of
presence and once it's on that point in
presence we terminate the request and we
afford it internally over our private
network and so more a longer portion of
the request is over a private network
where we have tighter control over the
quality of service we can provide so
that's that's a pretty nice benefit we
also end up doing automatic failover so
we'll find the nearest replica in this
particular case it's in region a and if
region a is and healthy will fall back
to region B automatically the third
thing that's nice about this is we have
like I mentioned earlier edge caching
and caching in our core data centers as
well so for a hot content subsequent
requests can be served directly from
cache rather than having to travel say
halfway around the world to the original
source
might be familiar with our cloud ciayton
product and might be saying hey this
sounds really familiar right and we're
very similar and that's exactly right we
actually use the same global network in
the same edge caching infrastructure
that's cloudy and so really a lot of
cloud CDN functionalities built straight
into GCS without you having to do
anything there are so some good reasons
for using cloud CDN in particular if you
want to set up SSL for custom domains or
you want to customize your URL structure
perhaps point subset of URLs at GCS and
a subset of URLs at your compute
instances you would want to use cloud CN
or a cloud load balancer
it also provides differentiated pricing
so you know some requests are served out
of cache some requests are served from
cache misses if you want differentiated
pricing there you can use cloud CDN so
next I'm gonna do a quick demo to sort
of demonstrate what I mean by this why
is global network so over here you can
see I've created a demo bucket you can
see it's a multi regional storage class
and it's locating the EU so it's a
pretty good distance away from you know
here in San Francisco I'm going to
switch over to terminal here and the
first thing I'll do is I'll ping our
bucket right here so I owe three two one
- demo dot storage aku api's comm and
what you can see here is that we're
getting a round-trip time of about three
milliseconds so clearly it's not going
to Europe right that's maybe 150 to 200
milliseconds away so the request is
getting terminated somewhere close let's
actually go ahead and perform a
traceroute
and what traceroute does is it shows you
all the hops that a request takes
towards its final destination and so you
can ignore our the first eleven or so
entries here the important one here is
this very last entry and you queue
something something one of you one
hundred done it so what is that right
first of all I I'm I'm sure a lot of you
guys already know this but Google itself
was actually miss named it was supposed
to be geo gol so if we look up the
definition of that it's one times ten to
the hundred right so and that's exactly
what one you 100 is it's our little
clever way of saying hey this is a
Google device if you look at the rest of
the name and I'm not gonna go into too
many of the details you can see nu Q and
you might wonder what that is so if we
do a quick search for that it looks like
it's a Moffett federal airfield here in
the Bay Area so you might guess that the
request is getting terminated it's
somewhere close by here right we have a
point of presence here and that's that's
what we're handling the request and once
it gets here we're gonna go on to Europe
right okay so next I've uploaded an
object into this year bucket and we can
perform a curl to pull the object and we
can time to time and see how long it'll
take
so here you can see I'm curling I'm just
silencing the output I'm you know
writing the output to Devon dole and I'm
pulling this food up in object alright
let's see what happens
see it's taking about 200 milliseconds
and that makes sense it's gotta traverse
all the way to Europe to get this thing
right so how do we actually enable this
edge caching what we can do is if you go
into your storage browser we can edit
the metadata properties of the object
and
here you can see that one of the
metadata properties is a cache control
header and it's being set to private so
if we wipe this out my default GCS will
use public world mark your object is
publicly cashable assuming your object
is actually public and it's private it
won't do this of course so I'm going to
just go ahead and clear this out
okay so now if I go back and we rerun
that curl command to pull the object
previously was about 200 milliseconds
we're now seeing about 20-ish
milliseconds 20 or 30 milliseconds so
that goes to show that the the objects
now cash closer to the edge and it's
being served straight from that so it's
a pretty simple technique obviously just
enable caching but it's one of the
things that I think it's not always
well-known is that we have this CDN
functionality built in and if you pair
it with the multi-regional storage class
you're talking about you know geo
diversity CDN like functionality all
sort of in one product without having to
do too much additional setup that said
you know we still definitely recommend
using independent CD ends there's nice
benefits to that they have different
reaches that Google has and so it's nice
having that additional reach it has nice
having the additional redundancy and it
also allows caching a private content so
if you do use a CDN one of the things we
recommend is a 7 origin shield what that
does is normally when you have a cache
miss all of your edge nodes are going to
fetch the data so that they can fill
their cache right
an ordinance she'll is an intermediate
cache where your edge nodes can talk to
the origin shield the origin shield can
fetch our data and then it can serve
that data back out to your edge nodes
and this is really nice especially if
you're using Coraline or Nearline where
the axis charges are little bit higher
that origin shield allows you know all
of your edge nodes to cache fill with a
single request the other thing is if you
do use an origin shield
I recommended multi-regional the
multi-regional storage class the
regional storage classes actually
sometimes useful as well because you can
place your origin shield and your and
your bucket very very close together and
then I'll give you a little bit tighter
control over your latency when there is
a cache miss it's a little tighter
control of your tale agency
okay third section is gonna be on right
scaling so this is a common pattern that
we see we see folks who are riding
objects and maybe there they're naming
the objects after the current time and
then riding them in order right so in
this particular case I have a whole
bunch of JPEGs and maybe they're being
timestamp on my camera and often that's
what we see is when this happens people
are able to scale the right rate for a
while and then all of a sudden they hit
this wall and they can't seem to get
over a certain rights per second so
what's going on here they kind of
understand we should actually take a
step back and see how Jesus was designed
and we started off with you know a few
requirements right back in the day we
wanted to be able to read and write data
and perhaps do that quickly and you know
that's not too bad right and then you
might add another requirement which is
hey you should probably be resilient to
power failure or hardware failure or
human failure so things are getting a
little bit harder but still kind of all
in all I think we can deal with this you
know we can use journaling to recover
from power failure replication you know
handle hardware failure and all sorts of
different techniques for human failure
backup slow roll outs automation testing
that sort of thing so we can we can take
care of this as well and then may be a
third requirement was hey we should
probably scale to lots of data and still
at this point it's not too bad right we
can we can use that as essentially a
distributed hash and the scale is pretty
well we distribute our objects pretty
evenly across all of our nodes we can
still do things relatively quickly
uuugh hash your object you quickly find
which node owns it and you directly to
that node there's not a lot of
intermediate layers there to cause
scaling bottlenecks and performance
bottlenecks so and I and I kind of you
know under played this because actually
there's a lot of smart folks who have
done this and we're lucky to be able to
rely on it but this was actually how one
of the initial versions that GCS was
built internally we we were essentially
as this big distributed you know hash so
unfortunately folks came along and said
hey it would be really nice if we could
list our data and we want to be able to
list our data in order we wanted to be
accurate which means you know we talked
about strong list consistency right
that's been one of the large requests
that we've had and we want to be able to
that quickly and so it's this last
requirement that really is problematic
it the distributed hash table really
doesn't work now there's no affinity
between objects that have similar names
and so in order for you to list in order
you essentially have to query every
single node the single node fails your
entire listing fails the single node
slow your entire listing is slow right
so this essentially forces us to do
sharding a little bit differently where
we shard objects into lexicographical
ranges so in this example I've got nine
ranges the first shard is any object
whose name comes before zero five dot
jpg right and the second shard is any
object whose name comes between zero
five jpg and 22 jpg and what GCS does is
it takes these shards in a distribution
to machines and here's an example we
have four machines and we distribute the
shards we of course have replications so
you could imagine having different zones
with replicas of these shards and we
don't necessarily have to distribute the
shards the same way but the key thing
here is in order for this to be
effective the amount of load that shards
1 2 & 3 receive has to be roughly equal
to the amount of load that 4 & 5 receive
& 6 & 7 & 8 & 9 right if we don't then
each of these 4 machines in that left
region are are they're not gonna have
even load balancing so the problem is
how do we decide what these
lexicographical ranges should be right
so that we get this nice even load
balancing it's actually little bit hard
primarily because we don't really
control what the object naming is and we
don't really control the access pattern
that our users use when they access our
objects so there's one example of
potential load versus object names and
here's an another very different example
right in that second example this could
be someone who's right
- - sub-directories foo and bar and not
writing anything else outside of that
and so only around foo and around bar do
you see these spikes and load and so
forth at where you would of course split
the ranges within foo and bar and for
this other one we would have probably
much more even splits right so one of
the key things here that I wanted to
point out is we need a little bit of
help
we have to really look at your past
behavior to try to figure out how to
assured that right if you maintain a
relatively consistent load we'll figure
it out we'll split things into the
appropriate jars and redistribute but if
you're constantly moving around then it
makes it very hard for us to react let's
go back to in order rights for a second
and see why these are problematic so if
we start out let's imagine we're writing
zero zero dot JPEG through ninety nine
dot JPEG in order okay and we'll start
off with the base where we have just a
single shard that means only a single
machine can handle these requests and so
we're writing these in order for on
machine number one and of course if we
wanted to use a second machine it's not
gonna be doing anything there's not a
shard that we can assign to that machine
and so with this current setup the
amount of right scaling you can get is
gonna be limited by the capacity of a
single machine
okay so one of the things we might think
to do is like let's put up our shards
let's see it's up to shards 0 through 50
50 through 99 and let's distribute each
of these shards to a different machine
right so what happens with in order
rights first of all you start writing 0
0 0 1 all the way through 49 all of
those hit that first shard all of those
end up on machine number 1
and while machine number 1 is handling
all these rights machine number 2 is
sitting there idle not doing anything at
all right and then you start writing 50
JPEG 51 jpg through 99 JPEG and these
all of sudden are hitting the second
shard which is hosted on machine number
2 and since all the requests are going
to machine number 2 machine number 1 is
idle so at any given point in time only
one machine is active and your total
write capacity is limited by that single
machine so this particular strategy
hasn't really bought us anything in
terms of our ability to scale writes we
could take this to the extreme and use a
ton of shards in this example we have a
bunch of shards one essentially for
every single object and if we distribute
those shards alternatingly between
machine one and two we can indeed use
both machine one and two simultaneously
and when we've doubled our write
throughput right but this isn't really
practical it doesn't scale well there's
a lot of overhead in terms of
maintaining shards and so that's one
issue and the other issue is that we
still have to be able to predict the
fact that you're writing sequentially
and do this type of splitting ahead of
time right we can't react after the fact
we have to know upfront that this is
happening so this is still fairly
problematic so the solution here is
really to change your write pattern for
example rather than writing 0 through 99
just sequentially you could go ahead and
write from two workers in parallel 0
through 49 50 through 99 if you do that
then this previous split into two shards
is actually pretty effective right you
end up hitting both machines 1 & 2 at
the same time you've essentially W right
through plate and if you do this by the
way GCS will figure out that these are
the right ranges that should be used for
the shards it just takes a little bit of
time
so let's to recap some of the best
practices for right scaling is for your
steady-state load and make sure you're
pointing your load at a consistent range
of objects if you're riding into the say
a foo subdirectory keep it in the foo
subdirectory over time Jesus is going to
figure out your you're right pattern
it's gonna split it's gonna scale if you
suddenly shift over to a different
prefix we will again you know react and
split and scale but we'll take some time
and you might see a little bit of a blip
in terms of gear right throughput if
you're doing a one off right where maybe
you don't have control over the names of
your objects parallel eyes alright
paralyze over different ranges this
particular problem doesn't affect
everybody roughly you can expect to be
able to get a low thousands of writes
per second before you end up with any
right scaling politics and we're working
pretty hard right now to actually raise
it quite a bit but just as a rough rule
of thumb if you expect to be able expect
to need to go over a few thousand writes
per second start planning for changing
your write access pattern to avoid these
bottlenecks and then finally you know in
terms of how quickly Jesus reacts you
want to think on the order of low number
of minutes so again it takes some time
to learn some time to react so it's not
maybe as quick as we like right
in terms of to get a little bit more
concrete in terms of what you can do
here I already mentioned the idea that
you can upload from multiple directories
in parallel that's one way to really
access multiple object ranges at once
another thing you can do is let's say
you're writing a bunch of obviously
quench lis so in this case your zero
zero five one two three jpg you can
actually hash that name and insert the
prefix of the hash and by doing that
since they're hash function is
distributed our is creating hash values
that should be uniform over the range of
hash values you're you're distributing
your load you're allowing GCS to go
ahead and create splits that are
effective and you don't necessarily have
to put this hash at the very beginning
of your object name so in this example
we inserted the hash after the food
directory and that means that any rights
that go into the food directory are
gonna be split and they're gonna scale
really really well and so that'll work
just fine again as long as you don't
suddenly shift your traffic from food to
a different prefix like bar
rescaling to wrap this up I wanted to
talk about retries a bit so here's a
typical retry strategy it should look
pretty familiar alright you get an error
you do exponential back-off you add
jitter things are great alright so one
question that kind of comes up is like
what's an appropriate timeout when i
when i call GCS you know you might say
something's on the short end like 500
milliseconds you might say something on
the long end to something like 10
seconds right so what's a good timeout
it's it's tough because there's a little
bit of a trade-off if you use a short
timeout then what's really nice is that
if you happen to hit a unlucky slow
machine that's maybe temporarily
overloaded you retry quickly and so you
control your Taylor agency pretty well
however if system-wide we're seeing a
slowdown then you might be prematurely
giving up right maybe if you had waited
just a second or two seconds your
request would complete and now all of a
sudden all of your requests are failing
because you've set this really short 500
millisecond timeout it also ends up
wasting a bunch of work right on the
server side on the flip side if you set
a really long time out then you're
resilient to these system-wide slowdowns
but you're you're now susceptible to Teo
agency again if I hit that unlucky
machine
I'm waiting around potentially for 10
seconds before our retry and if I'd
simply retried faster I could've got
back into the user a lot quicker right
actually want to mention is that tailor
agency is sometimes a bigger problem
than you might imagine
so for example let's say we're looking
measuring Calais to see at 99th
percentile so one out of every 100
requests is taking say one second and
for any given user visible operation you
might be doing a whole bunch of
lower-level operations so in this
particular case let's assume you're
making 50 parallel reads to GCS and you
need to wait for all them to complete
before you can you consider your job
done right and but this is again this
doesn't necessary have to be GCS you can
imagine loading a web page you're
loading multiple assets it basically
there's a lot of sub operations I really
have to complete before you're done well
unfortunately if there's a 99% chance
that you succeeded in that any
particular requests succeeds in one
second
then there's 0.99 raised to the 50th
chance that all 50 of those requests are
going to succeed within one second and
that's surprisingly low it's less than
61% so all of a sudden you're talking
about a property that really only
affects one out of a hundred requests
it's causing over a third of your jobs
to be slow right so it can be surprising
like there's a there's a bigger
intelligence you can have a bigger
impact on median latency and on your on
your overall latency
once you step up so one of the
strategies you can use for a
dressing-table agency is something
called hedge request so the idea here is
let's say we start an attempt we make an
RPC and it's taking awhile it's it's it
hasn't come back yet
we can designate some type of timeout
and I'll go into more detail like what a
good timeout is but for now let's
suppose we wait tell our expected 95th
percentile agency and we still haven't
gotten response yet at this point you
can actually submit a second attempt you
don't cancel the first attempt you don't
mark it as failures just to submit the
second attempt right and because we've
chosen 95th percentile agency as our
cutoff in theory that should only
generate about 5% extra traffic so it's
manageable right now if this were a case
where we simply were hitting an unlucky
machine an unhealthy machine
and and that's it it's not a system-wide
issue then this retry chances are it's
going to hit a healthy machine and it's
gonna complete pretty quickly because
typically your median or your common
latency is much much shorter than your
tail agency so if that's the case then
you're type number two is going to
succeed you can cancel attempt number
one you can go ahead and return the
result from from your second attempt
right
what happens if we were in system-wide
overload though well the nice thing with
this approach is that you never actually
canceled attempt number one you didn't
use an artificially low timeout right
youyou kept say a reasonable five or ten
second timeout and so if the overall
systems slow and maybe all requests are
taking about two seconds you can still
wait for a camp number one to complete
or attempt number two but in this
particular case a temp number one was
started earlier chances are is it'll
complete sooner so once a temp number
one succeeds you again cancel attempt
number two and you go ahead and return
the result from attempt number one so
this is a head retry strategy it's it's
really nice in this particular case we
use the 95th percentile as a cut-off you
can expect that impact your tail agency
at a longer tail right so a couple of
notes around this I mentioned that if we
chose the 95th percentile cut off we had
generate about 5% extra retry traffic
that's not always true 95th percentile
agency can change over time
right so temporarily what you think is
95th percentile ladies maybe the entire
system gets low and now your retrying
every single request so it's safer to
put a hard cap in terms of how many head
requests you perform maybe you limit to
X percent of your overall traffic say
five percent or 10 percent and that way
when you're going through these
transitions you're not going to generate
a retry storm
general recommendation is in order to
retry you really need to have
idempotence right and this means that I
can perform an operation multiple times
and the end results going to be the same
and there's a couple of cases where this
is not obvious where a particular
request might be I didn't but a sequence
of requests isn't so for example let's
suppose I write a to an object and then
I write follow it up and I overwrite
that with B okay now let's suppose that
first attempt when I wrote a it was it
was being a little bit slow so I made an
attempt I tried to write a it's taking a
long time so I go ahead and I retry and
that second attempt succeeds so now
we've written a I move on I write B and
unfortunately that first attempt to
write a finishes up so what does it do
it overwrites B and the net was a the
net result is I'm left with a right and
that's that's unexpected you would
expect that that retry or that a slow
request to be dead and not not have any
effect but it's actually living in the
system somewhere and kind of coming back
to bite you so one of theirs I mean
there's a couple ways to work around
this one obvious way is simply don't
overwrite objects right anytime you
write new content choose a different
name if you do this you're not gonna
ever run into this this type of issue
you can also use preconditions for
example if I had said write a if and
only if the object didn't exist
previously right and then I could say
write B only if the contents of the
object or the version of the object was
a if you do this then that initial
request to a is not going to over IB
because B's the object exists at that
point right and
wanted to point out exponential back-off
legit or like the standard retry
strategy you should still be doing it
and really think of it as focusing on
when you get an error right if I get an
immediate five oh three or four to nine
servers telling me to back off or that
it's unhealthy of course you've
continued to ask for national back off
with jitter this head retry strategy in
some ways is it's it's orthogonal it
allows you to address your tailor agency
okay so that's that's everything we had
today just so quickly recap we we
covered four different areas data
processing content serving right scaling
and reprise and you know be careful with
the source classes that you choose make
sure you're favoring larger requests and
you're paralyzing as much as possible
right make sure you're turning on
caching so you can take advantage of our
built-in CDN functionality and then make
sure your your your right pattern is it
going to generate bottlenecks unexpected
ball and that's later on and then
finally think about using a hedge
requests to cut down on your tail agency
so all right thank you everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
you